>> HOW SILENTLY, HOW SILENTLY
THE WONDERS GIFT IS GIVEN.
THERE IS A CERTAIN STILLNESS AT
THE CENTER OF THE CHRISTMAS
STORY.
SILENT NIGHT, WHEN ALL THE
WORLD GOES QUIET.
AND ALL THE GLAMOUR, ALL THE
NOISE, EVERYTHING THAT DIVIDES
US, EVERYTHING THAT PITS US
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER, EVERYTHING
THAT SEEMS SO IMPORTANT REALLY
ISN'T.
IT ALL FADES AWAY IN THE
STILLNESS OF THE WINTERS
EVENING.
AND WE LOOK TO THE SKY, TO THE
LONE STAR SHUTTING BRIGHTER
THAN ALL THE REST, GUIDING US
TO THE BIRTH OF A CHILD, CHILD
CHRISTIANS BELIEVED TO BE THE
SON OF GOD.
MIRACULOUSLY NOW, HERE AMONG US
ON EARTH, BRINGING HOPE, LOVE,
AND PEACE, JOY TO THE WORLD.
YES, IT'S THE STORY THAT IS
2000 YEARS OLD, BUT IT'S STILL
VERY MUCH ALIVE TODAY.
JUST LOOK INTO THE EYES OF A
CHILD ON CHRISTMAS MORNING.
LISTEN TO THE LAUGHTER WITH
FAMILY TOGETHER THIS HOLIDAY
SEASON, AFTER YEARS OF BEING A
PART.
FEEL THE HOPE RISING INTO YOUR
CHEST AS USING HARK THE HERALD
ANGELS SING.
EVEN THOUGH YOU SOME COUNTLESS
TIMES BEFORE.
YES, EVEN AFTER 2000 YEARS,
CHRISTMAS STILL HAS THE POWER
TO LIFT US UP, TO BRING US
TOGETHER, TO CHANGE LIVES,
CHANGED THE WORLD.
YOUR CHRISTMAS STORY IS AT THE
HEART OF THE CHRISTIAN FAITHS.
BUT THE MESSAGE OF HOPE, LOVE,
PEACE, AND JOY, THEY ARE ALSO
UNIVERSAL.
IT SPEAKS TO ALL OF US, WHETHER
WE ARE CHRISTIAN, JEWISH, HINDU,
MUSLIM, BUDDHIST, OR ANY OTHER
FAITH, OR NO FAITH AT ALL.
IT SPEAKS TO ALL OF US.
AS HUMAN BEINGS, WE ARE HERE ON
THIS EARTH TO CARE FOR ONE
ANOTHER, TO LOOK OUT FOR ONE
ANOTHER, TO LOVE ONE ANOTHER.
THE MESSAGE OF CHRISTMAS IS
ALWAYS IMPORTANT, IT'S
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THROUGH
TOUGH TIMES, LIKE THE ONES WE
HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
THE PANDEMIC HAS TAKEN SO MUCH
FROM US.
WE'VE LOST SO MUCH TIME WITH
ONE ANOTHER, WE'VE LOST SO MANY
PEOPLE, PEOPLE WE LOVE.
OVER 1 MILLION LIVES LOST IN
AMERICA ALONE.
THAT IS 1 MILLION EMPTY CHAIRS,
BREAKING HEARTS AND HOMES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OUR POLITICS HAVE GOTTEN SO
ANGRY, SO MEAN, SO PARTISAN.
AND TOO OFTEN, WE SEE EACH
OTHER AS ENEMIES, NOT
NEIGHBORS.
AS DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS,
NOT AS FELLOW AMERICANS.
WE HAVE BECOME TOO DIVIDED.
BUT AS TOUGH AS THESE TIMES
HAVE BEEN, IF WE LOOK A LITTLE
CLOSER, WE SEE BRIGHT SPOTS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE STRENGTH, THE DETERMINATION,
THE RESILIENCE THAT HAS LONG
DEFINED AMERICA.
WE ARE SURELY MAKING PROGRESS,
THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER.
COVID NO LONGER CONTROLS OUR
LIVES, KIDS ARE BACK IN SCHOOL,
PEOPLE ARE BACK TO WORK.
IN FACT, MORE PEOPLE ARE
WORKING THAN EVER BEFORE.
AMERICANS ABILITY --
INVADING AGAIN, DREAMING AGAIN.
SO, MY HOPE THIS CHRISTMAS
SEASON IS THAT WE TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS OF QUIET REFLECTION,
FIND THAT STILLNESS IN THE
HEART OF CHRISTMAS THAT IS AT
THE HEART OF CHRISTMAS AND LOOK,
REALLY LOOK AT EACH OTHER.
NOT AS DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS,
NOT AS MEMBERS OF TEAM RED OR
TEAM BLUE, BUT AS WHO WE REALLY
ARE.
FELLOW AMERICANS.
FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS WORTHY OF
BEING TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
I SINCERELY HOPE THIS HOLIDAY
SEASON WILL DRAIN THE POISON
THAT HAS INFECTED OUR POLITICS
AND SETS AGAINST ONE ANOTHER.
I HOPE THIS CHRISTMAS SEASON
MARKS A FRESH START FOR OUR
NATION, BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT UNITES US AS AMERICANS.
SO MUCH MORE THAT UNITES US
THEN DIVIDES US.
WE ARE TRULY BLESSED TO LIVE IN
THIS NATION.
AND I TRULY HOPE WE TAKE THE
TIME TO LOOK OUT, LOOK OUT FOR
ONE ANOTHER, NOT AT ONE ANOTHER,
FOR ONE ANOTHER.
SO MANY PEOPLE STRUGGLE ON
CHRISTMAS.
IT COULD BE A TIME OF GREAT
PAIN AND TERRIBLE LONELINESS.
I KNOW, LIKE MANY OF YOU KNOW,
IT WAS 50 YEARS AGO THIS WEEK
THAT I LOST MY FIRST WIFE, MY
INFANT DAUGHTER IN A CAR
ACCIDENT.
MY TWO SONS WERE BADLY INJURED
WHEN THEY WERE OUT SHOPPING FOR
CHRISTMAS TREES.
I KNOW HOW HARD THIS TIME OF
YEAR CAN BE.
BUT HERE IS WHAT I LEARNED LONG
AGO.
NO ONE, NO ONE CAN EVER KNOW
WHAT SOMEONE ELSE IS GOING
THROUGH.
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON IN THEIR
LIFE?
WHAT ARE THEY STRUGGLING WITH?
WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO
OVERCOME?
THAT IS WHY SOMETIMES, THE
SMALLEST ACT OF KINDNESS CAN
MEAN SO MUCH.
A SIMPLE SMILE, A HUG, AN
UNEXPECTED PHONE CALL, A QUIET
CUP OF COFFEE.
SIMPLE ACTS OF KINDNESS THAT
CAN LIFT A SPIRIT, PROVIDE
COMFORT, AND PERHAPS MAYBE EVEN
SAVE A LIFE.
SO, THIS CHRISTMAS, LET'S
SPREAD A LITTLE KINDNESS.
THIS CHRISTMAS, LET'S BE THAT
HELPING HAND, THAT STRONG
SHOULDER, THAT FRIENDLY VOICE,
WHEN NO ONE ELSE SEEMS TO CARE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE STRUGGLING IN
TROUBLE, IN NEED.
IT JUST MIGHT BE THE BEST GIFTS
YOU CAN EVER GIVE.
LET'S BE SURE TO REMEMBER BRAVE
WOMEN AND BED AND UNIFORM WILL
DEFEND AND PROTECT OUR NATION.
MANY OF THEM, MANY ARE AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AT THIS
TIME OF YEAR.
LET'S KEEP THEM IN OUR PRAYERS.
YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE CHRISTMAS
IS A SEASON OF HOPE AND
THROUGHOUT THE LIFE OF THIS
COUNTRY, IT HAS BEEN DURING THE
WEEKS OF DECEMBER, EVEN IN THE
MIDST OF SOME OF OUR TOUGHEST
DAYS, SOME OF THE BEST CHAPTERS
OF OUR STORY HAVE BEEN WRITTEN.
IT WAS DURING THESE WEEKS BACK
IN 1862 THAT PRESIDENT LINCOLN
PREPARED THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION, WHICH YOU SHOULD
ON NEW YEAR'S DAY.
IN CHRISTMAS 1941, THE WEEK
AFTER PEARL HARBOR, FRANKLIN
DELANO ROOSEVELT HOSTED WINSTON
CHURCHILL IN THIS WHITE HOUSE.
TOGETHER, THEY PLANNED THE
ALLIED STRATEGY TO DEFEAT
FASCISM AND AUTOCRACY, AND IT
WAS 1968 THAT THE MOST TERRIBLE
YEAR OF YEARS, YEAR OF
ASSASSINATION, OF, RIDE WAR, IN
CHAOS, THAT THE ASTRONAUTS OF
APOLLO EIGHT CIRCLE THE MOON
AND SPOKE TO US HERE ON EARTH
FROM THE SILENCE OF SPACE ON A
SILENT NIGHT, ON A CHRISTMAS
EVE.
THEY READ THE STORY OF
CHRISTMAS CREATION FROM THE
KING JAMES BIBLE.
IN THE BEGINNING, GOD CREATED
HEAVEN AND EARTH.
GOD SAID, LET THERE BE LIGHT,
AND THERE WAS LIGHT.
THAT LIGHT IS STILL WITH US,
ILLUMINATED THE WAY FORWARD TO
AMERICA AND THE CITIZENS OF THE
WORLD.
A LIGHT THAT BURNED IN THE
BEGINNING AND AT BETHLEHEM.
LIGHT THAT SHINES STILL TODAY
IN OUR OWN TIME, OUR OWN LIVES,
AS WE SING HOLY NIGHT, AS LOVE
AND AS GOSPEL AS PIECE, I WISH
YOU, AND FOR YOU, AND FOR OUR
NATION, NOW AND ALWAYS, IS THAT
WE WILL LIVE IN THE LIGHT, THE
LIGHT OF LIBERTY AND HOPE, LOVE
AND GENEROSITY, OF KINDNESS AND
COMPASSION, OF DIGNITY AND
DECENCY.
SO, FROM THE BIDEN FAMILY, WE
WISH YOU AND YOUR FAMILY PEACE,
JOY, HEALTH, AND HAPPINESS.
MERRY CHRISTMAS, HAPPY HOLIDAYS,